semaines d'élections dans plusieurs pays
en france le référendum sur la nouvelle
calédonie se fera dimanche prochain dans
le territoire c'est l'expectative
en israël les élections auront lieu
mardi 1er novembre le vote arabe des
arabes israéliens sera l'un des enjeux
du scrutin en algérie à référendum
jeudi se fera le 3 beaucoup de
changements à la veille du référendum
les jeunes se sentent nobility bonsoir
et tout d'abord l'opération drapeau
blanc nous sommes à mi-chemin le grand
week-end de la toussaint ces quatre
jours quatre jours difficiles pour la
circulation puisque 5 millions de
personnes se croient dans toutes les
peaux en tout sur la route
alors comment premier bilan comment
s'est passé ce comment se sont passées
ces deux premiers jours tout de suite je
me retrouve vers claude sérillon claude
voyez alors quelques chiffres d'abord ce
qui concerne la tranche 15 heures 18
heures d'hier la praye repas dominical
on avait des craintes on avait raison
d'en avoir
voici les chiffres pour 1988 comparés à
ceux 1983 je vous rappelle qu'on compare
la toux 5,83 115 accident il en a 74
cette année 7 meur en 83 8 entre 15h et
18h aujourd'hui 197 blessés 128 blessés
effectivement on pouvait craindre ce
genre de choses car on s'est un petit
peu relâché il a fait beau donc on a
roulé peut-être un peu trop vite
en cumul depuis le début de l'opération
c'est à dire une cinquantaine d'heures
voici les chiffres qui sont ainsi ici
sur ces panneaux 1980 342 on en a onze
197 tuées 104 67 morts en 88 blessés
3543 aujourd'hui 1652 toujours pour la
pour cinquante et une heure voici ce que
cela donne en nombre de vies sauvées
nous étions à 38
malheureusement le chiffre est en
régression d'un point vous allez le voir
s'inscrire derrière moi deux tandis que
l'on vous montre les pourcentages du
nombre de tués sur cinquante et une
heure tu es -36% blessés -35% accident
-27% céchi sont évidemment encourageant
mais lorsque l'on passe de 38 à 37 vie
sauve et ça ça atténue un petit peu
cette espérance
il faut continuer continuer à hisser le
drapeau blanc continue à respecter les
limitations de vitesse
et pour le drapeau blanc avec l'institut
lavialle et or team voici ce que la
donne 14 % de gens ont hissé le drapeau
blanc
on voit également le nombre de personnes
qui respectent qui porte le drapeau
blanc et qui respectent la limitation de
vitesse 73% respectées limitation de
vitesse voilà les deux illustrations
qu'on pouvait faire et puis également le
port de la ceinture alors là c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant ça montre que
l'incitation peut être grande 99% des
gens qui ont hissé le drapeau blanc
forte la ceinture de sécurité et le
chiffre est légèrement inférieur pour
ceux qui n'ont pas encore fait ce geste
volontaire de hisser le drapeau blanc
donc c'est bien il faut continuer c'est
jusqu'à mercredi hervé vous claude dès
ce soir claude oui
prochain rendez vous dès ce soir jeudi
alors on se retrouve à 21h55
et à minuit pour un spécial drapeau
blanc avec gérard holtz merci claude est
né voici encore ce fait divers ordinaire
cela s'est passé place d'italie à paris
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi deux
jeunes chauffards ont renversé trois
piétons ils ont pris la fuite les
piétons sont blessés la police rattraper
les chauffards ils ont passé la nuit au
commissariat on leur a retiré leur
permis ils devront payer une forte
amende pour cette opération drapeau
blanc nous avons décidé de tout montrer
la prise de conscience de notre conduite
collective est à ce prix l'un de nos
reporters philippe bertille a rencontré
les chauffards lorsqu'il sortait de chez
le juge
interview express
bonjour bonjour voila je viens vous voir
parce que vous avez renversé trois
personnes et vous avez pris la fuite
vous rendez compte que c'est grave très
grave
oui ouais mais on a eu peur la panique
et c'est tout
et quand ça s'est passé mais voilà on
rouler tranquille et sur la place en
plus si mouillé c'est mouillé et
pourquoi pas les personnes et s'est
renversée sous et pourquoi vous avez
pris la fuite parce qu'on la panique s
où il a paniqué il ya eu peur et
pourquoi lui du sorcier en plus les prix
bas est tombé en même temps et les
parties on s'est sauvé vous rendez
compte que vous auriez pu tuer les gens
je sais on serait très bien
et là vous avez passé la nuit en prison
vous avez réfléchi
alors être affichés aux on a passé
samedi matin on lui chercher samedi
matin jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est pour qui
ça et là on vous on vise à supprimer le
pain de conduire c'est ça qu'est ce qui
va se passer maintenant pour vous il a
rendez vous mercredi là pour moi je suis
complice moi je suis aux complices de
leadership et de chaux rendre le
conduire mercredi est appréhendé vers
sid
dix mille francs vous savez a changé
quelque chose dans votre comportement au
volant dans les jours les semaines qui
viennent
moi je crois là j'ai compris
le référendum sur la nouvelle calédonie
c'est dimanche prochain un scrutin qui
semble ne pas passionner vraiment les
électeurs même si le ton est monté cette
semaine entre les leaders politiques
mais sur place que se passe-t-il comment
les calédoniens se sentent ils concernés
par ce référendum est bien là encore
dans le territoire il y a une certaine
réserve
reportage dominique tierces bruno
carette plutôt discrète la campagne
électorale en nouvelle calédonie et
surtout économique pas ou très peu
d'affichage détail révélateur du
comportement des partis politiques
nationaux et locaux
bref il y à bien longtemps que sur ce
territoire une campagne électorale était
passé aussi inaperçu
de quoi plonger certains électeurs dans
la perplexité
ça sent le mésolithique annoncé flux
qu'est ce qu'ils vont voter maintenant
ça change tout le temps pas
c'est harry potter ans steven c
ils signent des accords et a pris pour
de fait seul le front national a occupé
pour l'instant le terrain avec 2
traditionnel meeting jean pierre
stirbois ils viennent le pen s'était
déplacé de métropole pour la
circonstance en partie pour paris ils
ont été relayés par roger blin
à ce jour aucune réunion publique n'est
programmée par le parti de jacques
lafleur le rpcr quant au fln cas s il
organisait aujourd'hui son premier et
unique rassemblement à nouméa la semaine
prochaine les membres du bureau
politique se déplaceront en mousse là
aussi on constate la mobilisation toute
relative des militants pas
l'enthousiasmé enfin c'est l'essence
même des accords matignon c'est les
accords matignon c'est un point
d'équilibré entre les revendications de
la fleur la revendication de jean marie
tjibaou
on s'y retrouve pas entièrement et puis
il faut dire aussi que le président
thibaut à renverser complètement la
stratégie de fela et son mets du temps
pour expliquer même si le taux de
participation est incertain tous les
calédoniens sont en mesure d'apprécier à
sa juste valeur le calme qui règne
aujourd'hui sur le territoire
seul incident noter pour l'instant une
bagarre entre mélanésiens et européen la
nuit dernière au cours d'un bal bien
arrosée au nord du territoire
les gendarmes arrivés sur les lieux pour
remettre de l'ordre ont essuyé des jets
de pierres quatre d'entre eux ont été
légèrement blessés un incident que tout
le monde s'accorde ici à classer dans la
rubrique des faits divers et pierre
mauroy le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste était aujourd'hui à
l'université des jeunes socialistes
justement écouter ce qu'il a dit à
propos du référendum de dimanche
prochain
on vous dira qu'il faut mobiliser tout
le parti socialiste se mobilise et que
le premier ministre est vide
nous sommes tous à ouvrir le débat y
avoir débat avec les français en tout
cas je ne veux pas commenter
l'abstention je dirais simplement aux
français et aux français si on peut le
dire tous cas ce geste de solidarité de
fraternité a été la poignée de main
entre la fleur et pippa au havre est ce
qu'on avait connu à ouvéa et agger je
pense qu'une français peuvent au moins
se déranger pendant le geste de
solidarité de fraternité
il consiste simplement à mettre un peu
la mort d'un esprit libre casamayor et
des magistrats il aimait la polémique il
était surtout indépendant toute sa
carrière a été jalonnée par une soif de
vérité qui ne l'a jamais quitté cavens
mayer avait 76 ans olivier lerner
hommage il faut le verbe acerbe la plume
violente casamayor m et a répété son
attachement au mot indépendance
indépendance des juges indépendance
d'esprit adversaire acharné de la peine
de mort ce juge d'instruction pas tout à
fait comme les autres
auteur d'une vingtaine de livres
conclure à l'un de ces essais par cette
phrase la peine de mort est un échec
conseiller à la cour d'appel de paris il
est suspendu de ses fonctions en 66 pour
avoir laissé entendre dans un article
publié dans le monde que le garde des
sceaux de l'époque jean foyer avait
donné l'ordre de conclure au suicide de
filles ont un truand mêlé à l'affairé
ben barka réintégré dans ses fonctions
quelques semaines plus tard nommé
président de chambre à la cour d'appel
de versailles en 78 casamayor n'aura de
cesse de critiquer le fonctionnement de
la justice le syndicat de la
magistrature n'hésite pas pour autant ce
soir à lui rendre hommage
quelque deux ans après cette affaire est
né le syndicat de la magistrature et des
magistrats ont commencé à s'exprimer à
briser cette loi du silence qui régnait
dans la magistrature
mais à l'époque cela n'existait pas la
raison pour laquelle cas de meyer a fait
peur et la raison pour laquelle il a été
suspendu de ses fonctions casamayor
s'est toujours battu et a toujours écrit
pour un fonctionnement plus extérieur de
la justice pour une justice plus ouverte
sur l'extérieur et il nous indiquait la
magistrature nous sommes tout à fait sûr
ses idées et nous les soutenons depuis
très longtemps et
et à l'heure actuelle casamayor est
encore très actuel dans notre pensée et
il le sera dans notre à devenir l'
incendie d'un chalutier français dans un
port espagnol levallois un chalutier de
lorient a été dévastée par les flammes
la nuit dernière cinq des six marins qui
se trouvaient à bord au moment de
l'incendié ont trouvé la mort pour
l'instant on ne connaît pas les causes
de cette catastrophe elle semble
accidentelle l'algérie dans le
tourbillon après les émeutes sanglantes
les changements et les choix mardi
prochain les algériens votent et en
quelques jours
l'algérie connaît en ce moment une
évolution très rapide réformes
politiques
plusieurs responsables limogés comme le
patron du fln on l'a appris hier soir et
aussi le retour d'anciens dirigeants sur
le devant de la scène
sur place la population s'apprête à
voter donc pour ce référendum les jeunes
particulièrement sont motivés bruno le
dreff reportage il vient d'avoir 18 ans
il a désormais le droit de voter ce
matin dès 9 heures comme des dizaines
d'autres ce jeune algérois
surreprésentés dans la mairie de
quartier pour obtenir sa carte
d'électeur dans cet arrondissement en
moins de quinze jours plus de 2700
nouveaux électeurs sont venus se faire
inscrire les algériens prennent bien au
sérieux le référendum du 3 novembre
une véritable course contre la montre
pour le ministère de l'intérieur chargé
d'organiser en quelques jours il a fallu
préparer urnes isoloirs bulletins de
vote et propagande agout 2
l'ogc en digne de nos grands
communicateurs le marketing publicitaire
vient d'ailleurs de faire son entrée
dans la politique algérienne une
campagne à la fois discrète et
omniprésente discrète parce qu'à sens
unique pas de mot d'ordre
contradictoires pas d'affichage sauvage
omniprésente car didactique il y à bien
une seule question êtes vous d'accord
avec les changements constitutionnels
qui vous sont proposés mais y répondre
nécessite l'appréhension de problèmes
complexes les problèmes détaillé examiné
commenté dans la presse écrite comme à
la télévision que la loi prenne bourrage
de crâne mais une volonté de faire
comprendre l'importance des changements
entraînés par les 20 nouveaux articles
de la constitution algérienne
si le résultat du référendum fait peu de
doute la plupart des algériens
souhaitent en effet une évolution
politique et surtout économique ce vote
constitue avant tout pour le président
chadli le moyen d'obtenir une vaste base
populaire sur laquelle appuyer sa
volonté de réforme
à l'autre bout de la méditerranée à
notre pays qui bouge là encore c'est
parce que les élections approchent il
s'agit d'israël
en israël les élections législatives ont
lieu mardi le premier set après midi
deux palestiniens ont été tués dans les
territoires occupés par israël des
territoires qui sont particulièrement
sous haute surveillance
al'approche des élections malgré les
renforts de militaires israéliens
les affrontements continuent et les
victimes aussi 27 liste pour ces
élections en israël mais en réalité deux
grands partis face à face le likoud et
les travaillistes pour l'instant fait
l'incertitude quant aux résultats
comment vont voter les effraie liens et
bien voici un premier élément de réponse
avec l'en quête de charles enderlin
ashkelon une petite ville au sud de tel
aviv
ashkelon a passé une mauvaise année
effrayé par le soulèvement palestinien
les touristes ne sont pas venus et puis
plusieurs habitants de la ville ont été
assassinés à gaza qui se trouve à 23 km
le problème de la coexistence le pose
ici au quotidien
un type de gaza qui rentrent ici
complètement zappé toute la semaine
bouliste ici chez nous tandis que moi je
peux pas rentrer un dessin et acheter
mieux que rien du tout parce que ces
jeunes entrant à gaza
là bas on youtube avec un couteau tandis
que lui roulante excuse et les magasins
qu'est ce que les besoins de gaza comme
eux et rentrer chez nous nous aussi on
peut rentrer chez eux
un peu plus loin crammed le colporteur à
trouver des interlocuteurs qui eux
acceptent le dialogue nous sommes tous
des fils d'abraham avec la paix
reviendra chez moi j'irai chez toi
inchallah si dieu ashkelon composé en
majorité de juifs originaires de pays
arabes vote plutôt likoud
à droite une exception afpi d'art le
quartier chic habitée surtout par des
originaires d'europe qui eux sont
travailliste 16h le qg du likoud ce
slogan veut dire la gauche c'est la mer
on prépare le meeting de ce soir le
thème le likoud sera écrasée l'intifada
le soulèvement palestinien de chez sûre
et certaine que vous des deux tours -
olten
comment est il ya des et nous avons des
programmes que ce n'est pas et le moment
de les étaler gabriel levy et pour une
politique dure c'est un partisan d'ariel
sharon quelques centaines de mètres plus
loin sur l'autoroute
les ouvriers palestiniens font du stop
pour entrer à gaza au boulot tous les
juifs me disent qu'ils sont pour les
travaillistes mais je sais qu'en fait
ils votent likoud 18 heures le meeting
du likoud a commencé 500 personnes sont
venues applaudir prédite équipe le fils
de mais la reine d'egypte
à l'autre bout de la ville le maire élie
dayal précampagne il représente la
nouvelle génération de juifs orientaux
militants travaillistes
c'est un quartier ils étaient 100 % les
coûts moi je ne peux pas dire ce que
dira 25% ont changé le nom parce que ils
savent que nous on travaille pour là on
va essayer de changer leur situation
son message il faut un accord politique
la paix permettra un développement
économique h que l'homme ce qui fera la
différence cette fois-ci ce sera
peut-être le vote des arabes israéliens
car il faut savoir qu'en israël parmi
les quatre millions et demi d'habitants
il y a six cent cinquante mille arabes
ils vivent dans l'état hébreu ils ont la
nationalité israélienne et ils votent
quand ils en ont l'âge bien sûr charles
enderlin a poursuivi son enquête dans un
petit village près de jérusalem où la
population est en majorité arabe
si les arabes israéliens votaient pour
un seul parti
il pourrait élire au moins quatorze
députés et constituer une force
politique dans tout gouvernement
israélien devrait tenir compte
seulement voilà ils sont divisés accord
de leurs voix presque tous les partis à
bourg gauche un village l'ouest de
jérusalem par exemple nous avons même
trouvé un partisan de renaissance un
mouvement annexionnistes d'extrême
droite samir affirme qu'il ne se sent
pas concerné par la situation en
cisjordanie
c'est un cas isolé en fait le vote arabe
sera déterminé par l'attitude des partis
à l'égard du problème pas liste
trois formations ont axé leur campagne
électorale sur le thème de négociations
avec l'ol paie les communistes notamment
devrait réaliser un beau score
au moins quatre députés estiment leurs
représentants à bout coche mais la
grande question c'est de savoir si les
électeurs arabe en voter utile renforcer
la gauche israélienne modéré le ma femme
par exemple qui a pris position en
faveur d'un état palestinien ou les
travaillistes pour qui seuls shimon
peres de relancer le processus de paix
ce sont peut-être les arabes israéliens
qui détiennent les clés de cette
élection d unité spéciale de lutte
contre le terrorisme cela hélas on y est
habitué dans les pays occidentaux
en revanche quand ces unités opère en
allemagne mais qu'elles sont américaines
il y a effectivement de quoi faire
réfléchir l' affaire a éclaté outre-rhin
et elle a bien sûr déclenché une
polémique
philippe rochot à bonn ces soldats
américains à mouthe langen sont chargés
de veiller sur les missiles nucléaires
ils sont à présent doublé par une unité
spécialisée antiterroriste dont le but
est d'empêcher qu'un groupe ne puissent
exercer un quelconque chantage à l'arme
atomique
ces bases sont particulièrement bien
protégés mais les missiles se déplacent
quotidiennement sur les routes
et c'est là qu'il ya danger en cas
d'accident un groupe terroriste peut
facilement attaqué un convoi de missiles
nucléaires
en 85 un camion transportant 1 pershing
s'est ainsi renversé dans un village
apportant la preuve que ces fusées
nucléaire était vulnérable et qu'il
fallait mieux les protéger
protestation pourtant du parti libéral
pour le comptes auto lansdorff les
pouvoirs de cette unité américaine sont
tellement étendues qu'il met en cause la
souveraineté allemande réaction du
porte-parole du gouvernement
l'action de cette unité antiterroriste
ne porte pas préjudice à notre
souveraineté
un communiqué bref mais jugé insuffisant
car l'accord secret passé des 76 avec le
chancelier helmut schmidt permettrait
aux américains eux-mêmes d'attaqué sur
le sol allemand d'éventuels terroristes
cherchant à s'emparer d'une arme
nucléaire
la presse allemande devrait même se
mettre à la disposition des autorités
américaines
les forces anti terroristes sont
stationnés dans cinq bases américaines
d'allemagne fédérale les gouvernements
alliés français britanniques ainsi que
trois autres pays européens possèdent
une copie de leur plan d'intervention en
cas d' attaque terroriste bat santé de
l'empereur hirohito s'est encore
aggravée il a une nouvelle hémorragie
plus forte que toutes les précédentes
depuis le début de sa maladie les
médecins sont inquiets je vous rappelle
que l'empereur du japon à 87 ans en
espagne la libération de l'industriel
emiliano revilla depuis 249 jours il
était fake est réparé le thé à sa
famille a vraisemblablement payer une
très forte rance question les contacts
ont-ils repris entre l'organisation
terroriste eta donc et gouvernement
espagnol rémy roche concert de klaxons
manifestations de joie émotion au pied
du domicile d'emiliano revilla
l'industriel espagnole considérée comme
l'une des plus grandes fortunes de son
pays est libre après 249 jours de
détention sans journaux des radios dans
un réduit de 2 mètres carrés il est
fatigué mais il va bien déclare ses
proches qui se refuse à dire si comme
l'affirment certaines sources une rançon
de près de 55 millions de francs a été
versée à le terrain militaire on se
souvient pourtant qu'à deux reprises à
paris en juillet et avant ici à bayonne
en février des membres de l'organisation
séparatiste basque avait été intercepté
par la police française porteur de très
grosses sommes d'argent sans aucun doute
tout ou partie de la rançon
cet épilogue de la nuit dernière va-t-il
permettre la reprise des contacts entre
le théâtre et les autorités espagnoles
contact précisément interrompu au moment
de l'enlèvement
rien n'est moins sûr dans l'immédiat
alors que les attentats se poursuivent
hier encore un policier tête abattue au
pays basque espagnol sans rapport la
maladie des années 80 et bien c'est le
stress récemment des médecins du travail
ont mené une enquête sur ce qui se
passait dans les entreprises d'après eux
les dégâts provoqués par le stress ont
considérablement augmenté au cours de
ces cinq dernières années
chômage cadence monde d'intérêt aussi
pour le travail et salariés les années
80 ont bien du mal à assumer
voyez-les en quête de delphine de la
selle c'est stressant 8 heures du matin
création et au pas du bruit de la fumée
la tension monte d'un cran et la journée
ne fait que commencer
maladie des temps modernes le stress
n'épargne personne
peur du chômage rentabilité à tout prix
la course au bien-être tourne au
cauchemar
numéro un la vie trépidante angoisse
c'est trop c'est trop c'est trop
sujet tabou tout le monde le vit mais
personne ne veut en parler et pourtant
les comportements liés au stress sont
significatifs et ce n'est pas toujours
les médecins qui font le premier
diagnostic
évidemment on a l'impression que des
gens ne trouve que deux solutions moins
qu'auparavant aux problèmes quotidiens
qui leur sont posées nous sommes
peut-être un petit peu les garants et
des médecins de ce serait des
populations puisque les gens étant de
plus en plus stressés mais font de plus
en plus appel aux sapeurs pompiers pour
des seuils beaucoup plus pas de problème
depuis dix ans la situation ne cesse de
se dégrader épidémie d'ulcère de
dépression l'organisme ne résiste pas à
la masse des pressions quotidiennes
les médecins du travail le constate tous
les jours
crainte du licenciement ou manque de
contrôle sur l'avenir professionnel pour
les uns tension permanente et aux
risques à la concentration et aux
décisions rapides pour les autres la
prospérité a un prix en france une
personne sur deux est victime de
troubles mentaux au cours de sa vie le
stress a un prix et c'est celui que l'on
paye à l'échelle d'un pays pour les
différentes maladies que l'on doit
soigner maladies cardiovasculaires
ulcère différents troubles intestinaux
les allergies aux etats-unis le coût du
stress a été évaluée à 3 % du produit
national brut l'équivalent pour notre
pays seraient d'environ 150 à 200
milliards de francs ce qui n'est pas
négligeable et ça représente
l'équivalent d'un gros budget tels que
celui de l'éducation nationale ou de la
défense nationale or à outrance loisirs
sans répit le culte de la forme engendre
lui aussi un nouveau type de stress
alors qu'il suffirait peut-être de se
rappeler combien il est bon
de rentrer chez soi et de s'installer
confortablement et sans complexe dans un
fauteuil
quelques résultats de sport qui ne vous
stresse pas trop j'espère d'abord le
tennis avec un vainqueur surprise au
tournoi de paris bercy c'est l'israélien
mansdorf il remporte le tournoi en
finale il a battu très facilement
l'américain gilberte l'eau des mares il
a raison de sourire amos mansdorf on
pensait qu'il ne passerait pas le
premier tour face à wilander et le voilà
le vainqueur du tournoi
c'est vrai que le suédois malade a
déclaré forfait mais l'italien a tout de
même battu rostagne au christine et la
sec en demi finale sans perdre un seul
set en finale son adversaire c'est
gilbert brad gilbert tu déjà finaliste
l'an passé
mais l'américain qui a bien joué pendant
la semaine perd un peu son tennis en
finale et d'israéliens en profite
montant même à la volée pour les points
importants alors l'américain essaie de
changer son jeu il monte à son tour au
filet mais rien à faire
manque d'offre le passe facilement 6 3 6
2 6 3 superbe victoire d'un mouvement
d'or
une victoire qui devrait l'emmener aux
alentours de la 20e place du classement
atp
l'once d'or que l'on retrouvera en
février puisque israël rencontrera la
france en coupe davis
sachez encore que l'équipe de france de
judo et championne par équipes elle a
battu l'allemagne de l'ouest en finale
des championnats avaient lu en belgique
et puis quand formule 1 c'est ayrton
senna qui est champion du monde après le
grand prix du japon qui avait lieu la
nuit dernière
regardez l'image qui va venir c'est à ce
moment que senna a dépassé alain prost
après avoir pris un très mauvais départ
proche ne pourra jamais rejoindre senna
le titre de toute façon ne pouvait pas
échapper à l'un des deux pilotes mclaren
voilà et puisque le sport ne guérit pas
le stress et d'un essayons la musique
jean-marc brami abordé le sujet par le
petit bout de la lorgnette si je puis
dire de quoi sont faits les instruments
de roseaux enfin pas tous les hanches de
certains d'entre eux sont en roseau
enquête chez michel portal en ce début
d'automne les roselières de la côte
varoise frémissent simple effet du
mistral pas sur la clarinette de michel
portal y est peut-être pour quelque
chose
car c'est un peu de leur cher que les
roseaux du midi l'est à chaque note du
divin mozart
comment
au simplement grâce à cette fine lamelle
qu'on appelle lance taille et tout
exprès pour les clarinettes les
saxophone hautbois et bassons et même
les cornemuses
sans elle point de vibrations et sans
vibration point de musique et c'est là
au coeur du pays provençal que l'on
produit traditionnellement les câbles
coupés sécher débiter et calibrer les
roseaux prennent leur temps dans les
mains de l'artisan avant de devenir le
compagnon souvent infidèles du musicien
ça s'est passé longtemps que je chacun
et les tice dans le monde entier
toujours en train de parler des hanches
je crois que les anges c'est ce qui pour
certains pas pour tous donnent une
appréhension clarinettiste c'est à dire
que l'enjeu c'est quelque chose qui qui
travaille toujours dans ce finalement
c'est la voix et si dans ma tête quand
je joue
je chante et si ça ne correspond pas du
tout à ce que nous sommes ce que j'ai ce
que j'entends dans ma tête je suis pas
content content ou pas content il faut
bien s'en accommoder une canne off entre
10 et 15 ans d'inégal qualité et
jusqu'ici personne n'a trouvé le moyen
de fabriquer un produit standard au
grand dam des instrumentistes
on repart à cheval pour le tiercé le
tiercé avais lues à haute et aujourd'hui
dans le prix d'angers on va voir tout de
suite les images de l'arrivée de ce
tiercé
je pensais qu'on allait voir les images
en tout cas vous avez les résultats
c'est 12 17 et 11
on les voit plus les rapports on va les
relire l'arrivée la voici les images les
chiffres maintenant l'arrivée donc 12 17
et 11 dans l'ordre 5307 fond dans le
désordre 694 carte est bien sûr 12 17 11
et 3,35 1832 francs 60 dans l'ordre fin
de cette édition du journal dans un
instant joseph dans la pierre pour les
prévisions de la météo pour la suite de
ce week end de la toussaint sont pas
mauvaises vous allez voir et puis la
dernière édition du journal ce sera à
23h15 avec philippe gassot excellente
soirée à demain soir planteurs
oh